it never dies and voce you know first
when I was at cafe hey God I was there
for a good chunk of time six years and
you know people were always approaching
me to do stuff and I was like no no no
leave me alone I'm having a good time
here and almost exclusively every time
it was they wanted to do something
Italian
and I said no to a lot of people for
many years on the Italian thing
discussed there's so many Italian
restaurants in New York I think it was
like three thousand or something like
that the last count I mean including
like pizza places and stuff like that
but they were like we love your Italian
you know we love your Italian food we
love you know the Italian things are
doing it at at cafe so it was really
kind of like again of a brash decision
we looked at this property and it at a
beautiful Terrace it's like yeah we do
something Italian here I mean the way I
approach Italian cooking is a little bit
different than other people I respect
approach Italian cooking it's uh it's my
own it's very personal to me it's not
it's not cookie cutter it's not super
traditional it's not it's just my own
kind of personal having a good time with
it
type of thing I and the way I do that
really is I just get inspired by places
I've been in Italy I probably in Italy
I don't know 25 times and I live there
for a year so if I'm thinking about I
don't know if I'm I'm thinking about
seaside sicily and we want to do I want
to do a dish you know it's gonna have
some wild fennel in it it's gonna have
some orange zest in it it's gonna have
some seafood in it and it's really I try
to make you know it's either a dish
that's maybe slightly whimsical and
within the Italian cosmetics or its
traditional in the sense where it's
inspired from a place and I'm thinking
about like the typography and I'm
thinking about the history and I'm
thinking about maybe the traffic that
was like you know there or just
everything about a certain place and I
try to make the dish evocative in a way
of where it is even though I might not
call it a you know a pesto genovese he I
might have those flavors in it if that
makes sense